I'm Janet Rankin.
I'm the Interim Director of
the Teaching and Learning Lab
here at MIT.
And for the past four years,
I've been teaching 595J.
It has a lot of other numbers,
but it's Teaching College-Level
Science and Engineering.
Well, before I
came to MIT, I was
on the faculty at
Brown University,
and I taught in the
engineering department there.
And it was very
interesting to me
how you could either do a really
good job teaching, or not so
good a job teaching.
So I started to get interested
in some of the theory
and some of the best
practices associated
with teaching specifically
to engineering,
but teaching in general.
And I worked in the
Teaching and Learning Center
at Brown for a while.
And so when there
was the opportunity
to come here and work at MIT in
the Teaching and Learning Lab,
I thought it would be great--
a great opportunity to come
and work with other scientists
and engineers who are also
interested in improving
teaching, or using
research-based best
practices in teaching.